[Music]
[Music]
okay
first i'd like to thank the unc for
rejecting my proposal
this time rather than show you
schematics i thought
i'll show you the real thing
project
magnus
the conductive transfer of an equal mass
and high tensile fiber or
as one of you call it
a rope
test
one point zero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
test 4.0
[Applause]
[Music]
technically this part
is supposed to go much further
technically
hi mom
hi how are you um
i'm fine okay
and you yeah i'm really good thanks
conductive transfer there's 17.
[Music]
i've got a new riddle for your mum ah go
for it so you have 50 fighters
each fighter has enough fuel to travel
100 passex okay
using all 50 fighters
what is the maximum distance you can
travel what class are the flight is um
it doesn't matter i don't know
it might matter
that's 44.
350 per sec
correct
fly them 50 percent drain house of you
until the other half fly runs repeat i
know honestly honey nothing nothing in
the current fleet will ever fly that far
[Music]
i
warships know glass arcadia
stay with us for continuing updates
test 63
test 17.
just said
[Music]
[Music]
oh
just talk to me
distance
78
i know it might not seem that but
you're getting there
you are
[Music]
[Music]
i miss you so much
[Music]
i miss you too
i can't wait to see you and all the what
you've done
[Music]
hey what's up everyone i'm bravo and
i've stuck my way back inside the 343
industry studio to check out a world
premiere of ranked and competitive
gameplay and i have the two best
gentlemen to do it with me here it's l
town sal of course of the competitive
insights team long time pro player great
to be with you again man and also andrew
witts lead designer on halo infinite
guys it's uh great to be with you today
i want to jump right in because like we
said the world premiere here of
competitive and ranked settings and
we're going to have gameplay in just a
moment but before we get into that
gameplay andrew i'd love to talk a
little bit about the philosophy of
ranked and competitive gameplay for halo
infinite we looked at competitive
settings the same way that we looked at
the rest of the game like we haven't
talked about it we wanted to be very
very halo to its core right and like
uphold the pillars of halo we really
wanted to make sure this uh the
competitive settings felt like
competitive hill like home battle rifle
starts only no secondary weapon
no motion tracker
and no grenade hit ticks so those are
the baseline settings across the game
for maps we have a static curated spawns
we work with the competitive insights
team to make sure that the scavenging
story on maps is really strong and
facilitates match control we want to
make sure the the team that wins is the
team that should win sure uh you'll have
to excuse me because i'm containing my
excitement here and i know a lot of a
lot of
fans of competitive halo over the years
will be really excited to hear about
these settings too and also to see them
in action so i think let's go ahead and
jump right into the gameplay uh right
now of course i'll time this is going to
be your gameplay that you've been so
kind to share with us this is going to
be a full pro team competitive insights
gameplay which is pretty cool to see
kind of all of you guys who have been
going at each other over the years
playing a game now here of strongholds
on recharge
those of you who've been playing in the
halo infinite flight weekends will of
course have been able to get your hands
on this exact game type but we're going
to now see it for the first time from a
competitive pov with competitive
settings of course also with some pro
player point of view so sal walk us
through the opening here strongholds on
recharge so this is strongholds
obviously you have to go for all the
strongholds but we're going for mid
control here and camo and my teammates
are mid-map kind of forcing those two
players into me i get the easy double i
get the triple as well where is it
and apparently i get the overkill too
yes i do so not a bad start complete
control and now i'm capping c not bad at
all not bad at all
i'm wondering i mean you know these guys
pretty well i don't know if any like
cash was exchanged to allow you to open
up with an overkill here on this world
premiere of competitive gameplay but uh
excited to to be able to look at this
gameplay here i think um one of the
first things that we of course want to
talk about is that stronghold has a game
type you were just talking about game
modes andrew and the fact that we have a
little bit of different score and
mechanics here which make a big
difference in terms of the end game
stronghold is returning from halo 5
really thought that it did very well in
halo 5 and no is well regarded by the
competitive community so we want to
iterate on it in meaningful ways and one
of those meaning wonderful ways is how
to contest and how scoring works in
strongholds when you own two zones you
begin scoring and now if the enemy enemy
team captures any progress towards one
of your zones it stops your scoring run
so that way you need to maintain
absolute control over all of your all of
your captured zones to continue scoring
yeah absolutely i think it's a great
change anyone who played a lot of halo 5
or watched a lot of halo 5 strongholds
will remember scenarios where they had
all the pieces in place to maybe get a
perfect comeback and even though they
were halfway through the cap on that
stronghold they needed uh as you call it
like the drip time allowed the other
team to win it felt a little bit
anticlimactic so i think a lot of people
have already seen in the halo infinite
flights the ability to stop everything
on the dime and come back is is pretty
fantastic to see
another thing we'll talk about here of
course is equipment style we're already
seeing you kind of use that equipment
and make sure that you're using grapple
to be everywhere you need to be on the
map right now yep just making sure i'm
getting resets and strongholds and
helping my team by getting those quick
flanks and quick routes another thing we
should talk about
of course is such a big piece of this
that we're going to see is that's just
the fact that we have motion tracker
disabled and how that impacts
moment-to-moment gameplay throughout the
entirety of competitive play you're
going to see a lot of examples of that
of course in this game but we should
talk guys andrew i'll start with you
just about the decision there and just
how much that impacts the gameplay
yeah we really wanted um the game to be
as competitive as possible working with
but have insights team to to kind of
make sure we measure up in that regard
and and part of the things one of the
things we wanted to kind of focus on was
awareness right awareness and
communication being really pivotal to uh
which is the better team that wins so
that's why we pursue that direction and
you'll see a lot of the of the outcomes
here in terms of how that rolls
yeah absolutely
you put it best when we were talking
earlier just before we started recording
just you know um talking about
information
earned and the fact that versus yeah
absolutely um just how important that is
yeah so we wanted players to actually
have to go out their way and get info
themselves versus like an indicator or
ui telling you where players are and how
weak they are so it's just more more
awareness and more skills and more
thought process on this yeah absolutely
as we take a look here
about 70 to 56 still a pretty close game
here uh as you're going to get oh and
get another reset here but you guys are
doing pretty well in terms of just
ability to continually rotate and
collapse on the opponent as well
yep just using some good comms here
collapsing on strongholds together
and nice pain switching going on right
here yeah absolutely
i think another thing we should talk
about too as you're going to go ahead
and get this kill
back hydro you're going to be able to
pick up we're going to see some sort and
some equipment places probably a good
opportunity to talk about some of the
equipment balance in the game so right
here i pair for poser and sword
to use to get some creative shortcuts
here right that guy had no idea so that
movement that shortcut mixed in with no
uh motion tracker
this allows you to make crazy plays like
that honestly yeah absolutely there's so
many pieces to talk about there just the
fact that you can creatively go from
bottom middle all the way up to top a
like that with the sword like you said
if someone is watching motion tracker in
a competitive setting they're gonna be
watching that doorway that play doesn't
really happen in those settings so it's
pretty fantastic to see and by the way
everyone's just running away from you
with their heads down at this point in
the game as you're racking up even more
kills but that brings us perfectly
actually to a camo pickup and the first
thing we'll talk about here is just the
new mechanic andrew of course people
have seen it but it's worth talking to
to to you as the designer on the
decision there of course uh in
conjunction with the sandbox team to to
make sure that the camo is actually
pocketable and you can determine when
you want to activate it
yeah the the sandbox team did an awesome
job working on the power equipment in
this game and so being able to pocket uh
power equipment and it taking the spot
of other equipment really brings more
agency in terms of how you want to use
the these items to your advantage right
and also hard decision making halo is
always about making a million decisions
like having a million decisions to to do
it in a given second right and what's
the best one
and this kind of adds to that right is
do i swap grapple shot for overshield
and do i use it now and then pick uh the
grapple shot back up what do i do what
is my combinatory effects with based on
what my current inventory is do i market
for the other teammates to kind of come
and pick up and contest with me
these are all the kind of questions that
we asked of ourselves and and um
ultimately you see here today is the
fruit of those labors right and make
sure that we test the hypothesis and it
worked
yeah it's pretty incredible to see just
you know the the term equipment on its
own and the history of competitive halo
has been
kind of a you know a a term that has uh
had an ebb and flow over the years of
how does equipment fit or not fit into
competitive halo so to see how much it's
not only being accepted but i would even
say embraced with things like clips on
twitter twitch etc has been pretty
amazing i'd love to talk about that
quickly just kind of the all-up
philosophy of
how you found this sweet spot balance
with the equipment that's in the game
that gives players some creativity
we wanted to make sure that the
equipment added to the skill of the game
right with us the skill gap and then the
skill sealing so the commentary effects
of like we saw before with style with
the repulsor as well as the the energy
sword right like the ability to traverse
the map the way he did adds that skill
uh both for uh newcomer players and also
pro players like themselves like the
experimentation the expression
was really important for us in
development in terms of adding these
things in
and then
fitting in with everything else in the
sandbox
sure here's another camo pickup sally
you guys have really been on top of that
camo and activated immediately and
probably the most interesting thing to
talk about there
right is the lack of grenade hit markers
that that player would have had in that
situation yeah exactly so that player
actually had no idea how much damage he
was actually doing or if he was even
hitting me yeah
he had to go out of his way to make sure
that i was weak and get the kill on me
my play right there was to make him
waste as much time as possible and to
put him in a spot where my teammates
could get the cleanup trade on him
absolutely and that's a situation that
plays out completely differently with
both motion tracker and grenade hit
markers on also forces that player to
even spend those grenades right so it
really changes the way that that plays
out it allows you to have so much more
power as a player there you're burning
camo you're spending that players
grenades and you're also taking that
player out of the situation there's
probably at least going to be a trade
there and it really changes the way that
all that plays out yup absolutely
another thing i'd love to talk about
here is we see more continuous control
from the salon team andrew is also just
a dynamic between of course we've got
the br utility weapon that so many
players will be excited to see but we're
also seeing sal use a lot of mangler
we're seeing some commando how you guys
really thought about the dynamic between
this utility weapon is really important
and it is such a core part of the
gameplay however the weapons on the
battlefield are also a big piece as well
yeah i think the sandbox team did a
really excellent job of making sure that
all the weapons have a specific role in
the game the battle rifle being the
utility weapon is really important to
being uh for players to being viable off
of spawn right they're having expression
off of spawn but we didn't want to have
have um
scavenging is so important to the game
right since we wanted to keep on having
them scavenge the battlefield how we did
that was we took away that secondary
weapon slot and have it be free so it's
only the battle rifle off of spawn and
so optimizers will want to fill their
inventory fill their pockets in order to
be able to be as effective as they
possibly can in a match so going with
that scavenging story of the map being
very curated with very specific items
and toys in the map and you know filling
up that their inventory is super
important
absolutely we see another camo grab here
from sal as well
this time i live that's a nice job
they're gonna be able to uh
to get away and also uh you know of
course be able to go away now with a
grapple camo mangler which is a pretty
sweet setup as well pretty ideal
see what i do with it let's go ahead and
see it at this point of course it's
right now 216 to 137 or one thing worth
talking about with that new score in
mechanics salads one sec we got a
contested stronghold here let's see how
you play this one out okay well done
uh takes down the first player i'm gonna
go ahead and finish that cap or almost
finish it but instead go ahead and up
nice grapple out but
that's okay it's okay uh one thing we
should talk about though at this point
because even though there's quite a gap
quite a delta between the scores in the
game you really can't take your foot off
the gas whereas in halo 5 you might be a
little more comfortable because you know
you have as long as you have control
with x amount of time left you're
probably going to win the game but with
the ability to stop everything like we
said earlier immediately while just
stepping into a stronghold that kind of
changes the way that competitor teams
will play the late game
especially with the new rule set where
you could contest and stop the pausing
for a little bit like you can't let your
your foot off the gas you got to try to
close out the game here so just making
sure we keep up the comms and the
teamwork
just pushing strongholds together yeah
absolutely and you've done it so well
here as well take a look at this play as
well as you're going to go ahead and
grapple him
unlucky
i'm lucky indeed but it's just worth
noting the fact that you do have kind of
that creativity right i mean
never has there been in competitive halo
a
a moment like that where you could fly
out of a door and then fly into an
entryway like that and be able to just
set up a play like that so it's pretty
special to see and the fact that it is
balanced the way that it is right is i'm
sure was quite a challenge andrew uh for
for a long time i'm sure
yeah we uh we tested a lot of different
things a lot of different settings but
we want to make sure that the graph
things that the grapple and really all
the equipment had had that expression
element right the things that are
powering all those clips that you're
seeing on the internet we're seeing that
we're all gleefully seen on the internet
we want to make sure that uh it's
important for expression with equipment
i want to do this i want to do this and
this i want to repulse somebody and then
follow up with with that mangler melee
or things like i want to put somebody
into a wall and knock them off of that
expression as paramount for for some of
the designs we've done this game
certainly i've seen some expression in
the forms of being repulsored off the
back of silo there by the hammer many
many times in matchmaking i've also
been on the receiving end of
overshield grappling hammer players on
behemoth so i've definitely seen
different forms of that expression um
getting the better of me throughout
these weekends as we take a look at
these last few seconds here sal closing
it out i think we're going to see
in just a moment you guys close this out
yes some celebratory needler shots to
end the game what better way to finish a
match as well 250 to 170 is our final
score there uh sal you guys ended out on
top a pretty strong performance i'm not
gonna lie appreciate it
we'll go ahead and take a look at the
post game carnage report too because uh
there's some sweet pgcr stats and some
people will have seen a little bit of
this in the post-game carnage reports in
the flighting but a few things that are
worth highlighting here of course you're
overkill but on top of that you've got
some cool things here in terms of
defensive kills offensive kills also
things like the max spree which people
will be familiar with but there's some
newcomers as well returning stats like
shots hit uh you know versus shots fired
but also one that you and i were talking
about is also damage taken which is a
cool stat down that's personally my
favorite because that is like the unsung
hero it tells a real story because some
players might have the most kills but
they're actually not having the most
influence on a map so damage taken is
part of that story where a person could
be causing chaos and getting shot up
from everyone on the opposing team like
a distraction like for example like
austin might have more kills but i could
be taking more damage because i'm making
it easier for him you know yeah
absolutely and as and as a commentator
as an analyst the fact that we now have
a piece of that story if you think of
the
hundreds of thousands of hours of
competitive halo gameplay that have
taken place uh just the fact that we've
never really had the story andrew of
damage taken and what that was for each
match so the fact that looking at halo
infinite tournaments we're going to have
have stats like that is pretty cool to
be able to see a piece of a halo match
that we've never really had the story of
before yeah it's just all this con this
conversation around stats and pgcr just
kind of makes me really happy because um
ultimate that's what this is this this
whole feature is for right is to tell
the story of the match of knowing how
did you how did you do how did your team
do how did the enemy team do right where
do you need to improve right or how
could you've done things better uh
really that whole story is why features
like this exist and so that we're
sitting here talking about like nuanced
stats and things like that it's like
it's really good just like being in this
moment time how close we are to to
launch totally yeah i think it gets us
excited i'm sure so many viewers as well
of this video getting kind of excited
about the those nuanced little details
just like you say uh l town i'll start
with you uh any any closing words uh as
we take a look at uh your gameplay here
and show off competitive and ranked
gameplay to the world honestly i'm just
excited for everyone to get their hands
on this we worked hard and i hope
everyone's happy with the settings we
landed on yeah absolutely
yeah likewise uh
myself and the rest of the team we work
on this for for a while really excited
to see uh
folks you know get their hands on it
right the flights have been really
exciting for us really invigorating for
us to see the response and all the
feedback right it's the same thing here
we're really excited to see
what the competitive community uh does
with this game with these settings uh
see what they're able to accomplish in
matches right see what ranked is like
see what uh hcs is like all this is just
super super great right now it's a good
it's a good time to be a halo fan yeah
it is as a halo fan and on behalf of the
whole community i just want to thank you
both for the amount of time love effort
you've put into this game because it is
already showing um in in you know in the
fighting in the excitement for the game
um and it was so special for me to play
such a small role in sitting with you
two with all the amount of work you've
put into this game to be part of this
competitive reveal is really special for
me so thank you both there's going to be
more information on halowaypoint.com on
competitive settings and you can find a
blog on even more details there of
course stay tuned to halo on twitter as
well as halo waypoint for even more as
we get ready of course and also at hcs
as we get ready for the first halo
tournament shortly after launch as well
that's going to do it for us for now uh
from the 343 livestream studio it's been
a pleasure showing off competitive
gameplay and we'll see you on december
8th
[Music]
[Music]
activating verbal reconstruction
begin
dear mr and mrs
[Music]
you don't know me
but i know you
i served with your son
he spoke of you
all the time
i was there
[Music]
we were ambushed by jackals
[Music]
david didn't flinch
he led
he was brave
and i followed him into battle
together we fought them off
but we paid a price
[Music]
while they carried us to the medivac
all he was worried about
was you
[Music]
i tried to tell him
that his parents would be proud
but
my throat
[Music]
and your son
he loved you
he loved you to the end
[Music]
hi i'm megan spurr community lead for
xbox game pass in today's pc community
update we're back to talk to you about
the xbox experience on windows since we
launched xbox game pass for pc and the
xbox app in 2019 which feels precisely
sometime between 9 minutes and 87 years
ago we've made a lot of updates to the
app we've made it easier for you to find
games that are coming and leaving soon
not to mention stock to the thing full
of amazing games and made the download
experience more reliable for all pc
games including a whole bunch that
arrived on day one with game pass for pc
that's a subtle plug there
today we're talking to jason beaumont
partner director of experiences with
xbox about some of the updates xbox
insiders will be able to test in the
xbox app on pc and what you can expect
in the future jason welcome back it's
been a minute since we've talked about
the xbox app and game pass yeah it's
great to see you again so tell me a
little bit about the updates that people
are going to be able to test soon in the
xbox app with xbox insiders uh as you
might know we had some legacy systems we
were working with we had uwp games and
all this stuff around delivery and
installation we made significant
improvements to those systems you know
they were leading some challenges for pc
gamers with just updating their apps
downloading installing especially
modding games we've been listening to
the feedback from everyone on what would
make gaming even better with the app and
we're excited to roll out these
foundational updates out to all of our
players soon so what's the first thing
that we're gonna notice we want you to
be able to choose where your games
install
soon xbox insiders can start testing out
selecting what drive your game installs
to and select where your default folder
goes within that drive
you'll also find that download speeds of
those games have improved over time so
it's even easier and faster to get to
your next game that's awesome one of the
biggest changes you're gonna find and i
know you mod a lot of games megan is
that soon uh for many games with an xbox
game pass you'll have access to your
local files that means you'll be able to
edit your game files move your files et
cetera shout out to the person who made
the mass effect mod that turns all fonts
into comic sans by the way
that wasn't gonna be the first mod that
i chose but in the xbox app you can look
at the game details and you'll see if a
game is modified
huge shout out and a big thank you to
our xbox insiders who will be testing
these new updates if you want to scope
out the new updates and share your
feedback before they release join the
xbox insiders now we'll put a link in
the description for more details on how
to join but let's talk about another big
update i think more of our pc gamers
with xbox game pass ultimate are going
to be impacted by this one and that's
cloud gaming yeah when you launch the
app now you'll see cloud gaming this is
a really cool experience for a lot of
people check out my cloud gaming
walkthrough you'll see a link in the
description below but essentially our
ultimate members now have access to play
almost instantly the xbox game pass
library of cloud enabled console games
from within the xbox app on pc exactly
this is great if you just can't get your
hands on one of the new consoles and
want to check out the great library of
console games we have an xbox game pass
and for people with older pcs or don't
have a gaming pc at all or if you're on
a work machine and playing games instead
of listening to a meeting that should
have just been an email yeah i admit
nothing
but seriously it's also great if you're
on pc but your friends are playing on
console this makes it really easy to
play together i've got one more thing to
point out that isn't necessarily in the
xbox app but i think for our early
adopters of windows 11 this month they
may want to know as you might know with
windows 11 microsoft implemented auto
hdr a really cool feature that takes a
lot of older games that weren't built
with hdr and moves them automatically
into high dynamic range i've been going
back and checking out some games and
it's crazy what a difference it makes
you're right but what some people might
find is that they want to play without
hdr or maybe that hdr is just too much
for certain games that's where an update
to xbox game bar comes in we have a
widget in game bar that will let you
toggle hdr on or off or you can use an
intensity slider to change how intense
the hdr is within your game i absolutely
love that i can totally see if you're
feeling some nostalgia games and you
want to go back and play but the hdr
just doesn't hit right with those games
so you just want to customize your
gameplay experience
now let's talk about some of the updates
that are still coming this year or later
next year we're continuously working on
updates for the xbox app and xbox game
pass for pc we'll continue to bash the
bugs as we find them but we have some
things coming up that people will be
excited about first up is we're
continuing to improve performance of the
app making it more reliable to download
and play your games we're absolutely not
done yet we keep listening to your
feedback and work behind the scenes to
make it even better next we're reducing
the friction for developers to bring
their games and implement game features
like cross saves achievements and other
benefits of our platforms and we're
making plugins for common engines like
unity and unreal
finally we're still innovating we're
going to keep working to make this a
great gaming platform for all pc gamers
we're all super excited to see the work
being done by the team
my very last question though is what are
you playing now i'm playing psychonauts
2 right now it's absolutely wonderful
all right well it's already in my
backlog thanks for walking us through
the roadmap of all the updates to come
yeah thank you for having me and thank
you everyone for tuning in remember go
join the xbox insiders if you want to
start testing updates to the xbox app
and please keep sending us your feedback
and we'll talk to you next time
[Music]
there are so many games on game pass you
got sea of thieves you got skyrim you
got wolfenstein too you got zuma zuma's
revenge and then add game pass ultimate
with ea play into the mix and you're
probably like yo hold your horse's xbox
i don't even know where to begin in this
wild ocean of gaming's best deal and hey
that's okay cause rest assured we have
the list for you the best xbox game pass
games to check out right now alright
let's kick this off for the scarier side
of game pass
and what scarier game to get this train
to spooky town roland than visage
imagine if a small team of french indie
developers decided to try and pick up
where hideo kojima's pt left off and
well uh that's exactly what visage is
even though yes it's very clearly a pt
clone what's truly impressive is how
developer sad square studio managed to
evolve and stretch kojima's concept into
something terrifyingly all its own it
checks all of the boxes housed with a
gruesome and tragic past hallways i have
no interest in exploring but ultimately
have to and this cutie
most inspiring is the lambrinthian maze
of the house and how it constantly
shifts shapes and morphs in maddening
ways as you go deeper and deeper into
the haunting twisted storyline
what's the deal with big houses that are
so damn eerie anyways well in resident
evil 7 it's not ghosts that's for sure
it's the damned baker family there's no
denying resident evil 7's got a little
pt influence in its dna too which
uprooted the survival horror franchise
and put it in terrifying first person
and boy did it work
it only came out a few years ago but
resident evil 7 has already found its
place as a modern classic in the
survival horror genre and if you haven't
braved the louisiana swamps to take on
the baker family just yet then well what
are you waiting for an invitation
welcome to the family song
but who says you gotta deal with
monsters alone visage and resident evil
7 are single player games but back for
blood hits the horde of horror against
you and three others it's the spiritual
successor to left for dead which means
you'll be blasting through massive
hordes of the undead or ridden as
they're called in the game and having to
think on the fly to communicate with
your team to take on special ridden
types like exploders who
explode or bruisers
who will
bruise you this game goes camping
because it's intense so you might want
to pair up with your friends or
strangers on this one thankfully though
you don't have to play with others if
you don't want to because it's got a
solo mode so don't worry you can be as
anti-social as your heart desires and
while we're on the subject if horror
games is your jam we did an entire list
detailing the best horror games you
should consider checking out right now
so you can find a link to that video in
the description below
[Music]
alright let's lighten the moon now shall
we the good life is a lot of things it's
an rpg it's an immersive sim you can
also take pictures make money on social
media to pay off your debt uh you can
also farm ride a sheep oh and uh
everyone in this rural english town just
so happens to turn into cats and dogs at
night in fact uh so can you
oh yeah and uh there's a gruesome
murderer mystery of foot did i mention
you can challenge a priest to a drinking
game the good life tries to be a lot and
while it doesn't quite nail everything
it attempts it makes up for it with
bucket loads of charm its characters are
quirky and memorable the story is
unpredictable and whimsical and it's
probably the most relaxed i've felt
playing a game in a long time there is
really quite nothing else like the good
life out there
psychonauts 2 it's the sequel to the 16
year old cult classic that continues the
story of the circus acrobatic psychic
prodigy raspberry but don't worry if you
haven't played the first you're in luck
psychonauts 2 gives a snappy recap and
does a great job of welcoming new
players to this marvelous world it's an
ambitious take on colorful 3d
platformers one that tells an impactful
and emotional story while also carefully
handling and approaching topics of
mental health in lighthearted and
considered ways
the forgotten city is definitely
something not to be forgotten it's a
time loop narrative game where you find
yourself in an ancient underground city
which is at the mercy of a fantastical
curse that kills everyone if one of its
citizens commits a sin however someone
is exploiting the power to wind back
time and it's up to you to experience
its final day over and over again until
you solve its mystery what unravels is a
thoughtful commentary on what's right
and wrong beliefs religions and morality
itself it's pretty heavy stuff but is
easily digestible thanks to some
incredibly well-written characters it's
a marvel of game design and writing
working an incredible tandem and one not
to forget about
[Music]
and speaking of being ancient have you
ever heard of a game called miss yeah
like the 1993 mist well it's on game
pass but this mist is different from the
geriatric classic that came out 28 years
ago this one has been built from the
ground up and unreal engine giving this
oldie more than just a facelift but
completely updated visuals and controls
making it the quintessential way to
experience an absolute og mist is an
adventure puzzle game set on a
beautifully surreal island this game is
notoriously cryptic and a little
difficult but i assure you when you
imagine to figure out these puzzles on
your own and you will you'll feel like
an absolute genius
even better its soundtrack has remained
completely unchanged further proving
that new age music from the 90s remains
forever timeless just like enya
so you know how you hear stories of
people who go off into the desert for
like eight months and experience this
euphoric spiritual awakening where they
suddenly understand the meaning of life
the cycle of existence all its
dimensions and that whole knowing in
that you know nothing stuff
anyways that's basically what it feels
like to play tetris effect connected and
best of all you can have the spiritual
awakening with a bunch of friends like
some meditative retreat because it's
multiplayer and it's just cool and stuff
hades isn't just among the most
innovative roguelikes out there it's
also the sexiest
hades uses the concept of dying over and
over again and uses it as a vessel to
unravel the story changing the
expectation of death is something more
than just failure but a rewarding
prospect and how the story is told
it's a hack and slash dungeon crawler
and for a while hades was pc and
nintendo switch only so having on game
passes a gift from well
the underworld
[Music]
microsoft flight simulator strap in and
fly anywhere in the world the game uses
real world data pulled from big maps to
inform the in-game ai to generate the
whole damn planet this franchise has
been exclusive to pc until this release
so the console edition is a marvel in
and of itself
now of course there's loads of games on
game pass and these are just a few you
should try out so be sure to check out
the other lists on game pass games to
play in the description below
okay thanks for watching until next time
see ya
[Music]
xbox it's had some excellent exclusives
these past few years and with all the
acquisitions microsoft's been
negotiating well that number is going to
be growing but in the meantime we put
together a list of 15 xbox exclusives to
sink your teeth into from indies to the
big hitters so let's get into it
microsoft flight simulator is an
absolute dazzling feat using real-world
data pulled from bing maps the game
generates a fully realized 3d earth
using ai you can fly anywhere in the
world to your house to your friend's
house to my house it's absolutely absurd
and using what only can be described as
magic updates the in-game earth to
reflect changing weather patterns like
massive storms or hurricanes it's just
bonkers oh and it's playable on console
for the first time in the series
existence on the xbox series x and s so
that's pretty sweet
sea of thieves is great teaming up with
three friends to set sail delegate
responsibilities control the ship
treasure hunt navigate an expansive sea
take on an enormous shark or just drink
until you throw up on each other never
ceases to entertain me and have you seen
how good this water looks look at it
it's just fantastic it's a shared world
game allowing you not to only set sail
with friends but encounter other players
too whether you want to help them ignore
them steal from them or kill them well
that's entirely up to you the game is
filled with natural discovery and plenty
of scenarios that flip the script and
force you and your friends to react on a
whim also have i mentioned how good that
water looks and recently it added a
crossover expansion with pirates of the
caribbean to pack in hours of
story-driven content
okay okay yeah this isn't one game but
rather
six games we're talking halo combat
evolved halo 2 3 odst reach and halo 4.
but look there's no denying it halo is
king and few franchises have had the
impact on the medium that halo has and
the master chief collection is the
encapsulation of all of that whether
you're thinking of just dipping your
toes into the sci-fi melodrama or jump
into an online death match everything
you need is right here in this
collection
you don't have to know all that much
about cars that strap in and have a
blast with forza horizon 4. this entry
in the series stands out for the
introduction of seasons each of which
provides a unique experience to the same
tracks a course that's easy to drive in
the summer may be a whole lot trickier
when there's ice in the ground go figure
it's also just one pretty game to look
at car fan or not there's no denying
that
gears 5 expanded the scope of the series
more so than any entry before it
incorporating open areas that give you
the opportunity to tread off the beaten
path and pursue optional objectives a
welcoming change of pace in the
otherwise linear gears formula but don't
be fooled it still rewards the same
quick reflexes with satisfyingly brutal
depictions of carnage but throws in some
extra flavor to how you tackle
challenges depending on how you approach
an enemy base or the weapons you're
going in with this also picks up right
after gears 4 playing as kate diaz and
based on this ending that story isn't
over quite yet and this probably goes
without saying but its multiplayer is as
top notch as ever
missed ah yes the cryptic puzzle game
classic this remake rebuilt the game
from the ground up with new art and
sound assets more interactions and even
an added option to randomize puzzles if
you're one of the veteran geniuses to
have actually finished this game like me
mist is absolutely great and this remake
makes an age-old classic from 1993
completely re-realized for the modern
age and if anything it's just worth
walking around exploring to hear its
soothing new age soundtrack
state of decay 2 has come a long way
since its launch expanding on its zombie
survival open world formula with
graphical overhauls new maps modes and
more story missions it's now a solid
game for those looking for that walking
dead experience where you're building
bases recruiting allies managing
resources maintaining relationships
scavenging for resources and creatively
fighting off hordes of the undead it's
also got co-op who said the zombie
apocalypse couldn't involve a little
teamwork
rare replay includes 30 games from the
studio's history from the era of the zx
spectrum to the 360. there is a hefty
heaping of titles from beat em up
battletoads and 3d platformer banjo
kazooie to the first person shooter
perfect dark and life simulator viva
pinata there's likely at least one title
included in rare replay that'll tickle
your fancy now unlike most games on this
list that are available on pc2 rare
replay is actually one of the very few
to be completely exclusive to an xbox
console
adios is a game about a farmer but not
just any farmer it's about a farmer
who's got a job on the side disposing
dead bodies from the mob by feeding them
to his pigs that is until one day he
calls it quits and well this isn't the
sort of gig someone just gets up and
walks away from the end result is a
cinematic first person story that asks
the player to grapple with themes of
morality and grief but grounds them in a
relatable tale about two people trying
to come to terms with their lives it's a
nuanced drama that's sure to linger with
you and is absolutely worth your time
[Music]
the big con is a 90s animated tv fueled
adventure game oozing heaping loads of
nostalgia from that culture in the big
con you play as ally a teenager roped
into a partnership with a con artist
after finding out her mother owes 100
000
to loan sharks thrusted onto a
cross-country trip ali is trying to
scrounge up any dime she can you'll be
planning your own cons and as a part of
the process strategically piece together
how to maximize the profits all of which
is held together with a solid story of a
young girl dealing with her mother's
expectations while handling her
blossoming queer feelings it's pretty
great and it's the debut title from
developer mighty yell
grounded is like if you took honey i
shrunk the kids and smashed it with
minecraft it's especially a fun setup if
you have friends to play it with you
build bases and weapons to protect you
from critters that well want to eat you
and in the process must uncover remnants
of a secret lab that may hold the key to
how you got shrunk in the first place oh
and if you don't do that well with
spiders don't worry it's got an
arachnophobia mode that makes them a
little less scary
ooblets is a bizarre but charming blend
of farming simulator and creature
collecting rpg so it's basically stardew
valley meets pokemon which is probably a
lot of people's dream game in this case
however instead of beating the creature
into submission and make it your own you
do a dance battle you play as the newest
resident of badge town where you're
given a worn down farm and the choice of
your starting ooblet as you fix up your
farm you'll be able to plant crops to
sell you can also journey across the
region and challenge other trainers in a
dance battle which kind of plays out
like a card based game as mentioned it's
bizarre but charming
in a lot of ways insomniac games sunset
overdrive is an early precursor to the
developers follow-up marvel's spider-man
it's an open-world action adventure that
makes you the superhero like guardian of
sunset city after an energy drink turns
most humans into mutant monsters like
marvel spider-man after it sunset
overdrive mixes combat and movement and
rewards you with bonuses for shooting
your arsenal of guns while wall running
grinding across phone lines or bouncing
on top of cars it's fun quite bombastic
and at times pretty hilarious
[Music]
the veil shadow of the crown is a
fascinating take on an action rpg
because
you're blind therefore all the usual
run-of-the-mill stuff you do in rpg like
fighting enemies sneaking around guards
firing a bow walking through the market
is all entirely done with sound you have
to listen to enemies shuffling around
you and exhaling as they swing a sword
to know where and when to parry an
attack or pick out the clinging of a
blacksmith's hammer and miss a busy
market to figure out where to go for new
armor it's totally unique and a
fascinating approach to an otherwise
cliche genre
[Music]
and there you have it the 15 definitive
games that all xbox one and series
console owner should consider checking
out thanks for watching and don't forget
to give us a thumbs if you found this
video helpful oh and if you're not
already consider subscribing too to stay
up to date for everything related to
gaming okay take care folks
[Music]
this is curtain devina speaking for
alessandro barbosa for all the luxury
cars that forza horizon 5 has to offer
the one i kept coming back to was an old
volkswagen beetle lovingly called avoca
by the mexican locals it was a reward
for a lengthy string of challenges all
taking liberties with what the
recognizable but otherwise unremarkable
car could be with the right love and
care more than that it became a special
car because of what it meant to one of
the main characters in forza horizon 5's
more personal story missions letting her
recount a love of racing that stemmed
from her grandfather's adventures with
this very vehicle
this single chapter encapsulates not
only why the horizon series was endured
but how developer playground games keeps
thoughtfully iterating on it it's not
just about the familiar high octane
racing it's also about the stories that
people and their cars can tell and what
it means to those who continue that
legacy
these moments accentuate a more personal
campaign that gives your created driver
more of a voice than previous entries
increasing the conversations between its
ensemble of racing hungry characters
while also giving plenty of
opportunities for its new locale to be
explored outside of the horizon festival
forza horizon 5 doesn't replace anything
with its shifted focus but instead
delivers another stellar open world
racing experience that delicately
balances arcade sensibilities with a
series of simulation routes
mexico is one of the best regions the
series has visited thus far too offering
a stunning backdrop to each race while
also providing varied services and
landmarks to make each one feel special
while the pristine countryside of
britain might have been a bit too
sterile for the ridiculous nature of the
globe-trotting verizon festival mexico
fits right in like the australian
outback in forza horizon 3 playground
games turns the map into a tasting menu
for all the features the country has to
offer from densely packed cities to
barren sand dunes and sun-kissed
coastlines the transition from one hub
to another feels natural as you zip
around the map but the visual variety
that each one offers gives each corner
of the map personality in a way that the
series was missing in its last outing
yeah thank you britain forza horizon has
been a technical and visual treat with
each release and this latest entry is no
different despite releasing on both the
older xbox one and the newer xbox series
x and s consoles playground games has
evolved its engine to bring out even
more details from the hundreds of cars
on offer and the gorgeous lighting that
bathes each of your excursions one of
the most impressive improvements is just
the sheer density of the map each corner
is teeming with small details that make
them stand out whether it's complicated
rock formations on the edge of an active
volcano bubbling with a warm orange glow
or the light scatter and destruction
caused by a furious sandstorm forza
horizon 5 is a stunner in both its
quality and performance modes and
especially so on the xbox series x which
is where i played it letting you get the
most out of your new console purchase
the variety of mexico is not just for
visual pleasure either with each of its
own distinct biomes offering small but
meaningful changes to racing services
and weather conditions that change the
way races play out
road races can only be slightly changed
by a rain's slick surface in a storm but
the same weather radically changes how a
mud-covered sprint in a dense forest
needs to be approached for example the
environment allows forza horizon 5 to
introduce new types of races too
including baja events the game's version
of dirt road races that play out over
the messy sand dunes near the coast or
the wild series that reintroduces
cross-country races but with far more
variable surfaces to play with weather
still gets cycled in and out during
real-world week-long sessions but these
are now regulated to seasonal events as
opposed to directly influencing the
entire open world races are also
designed with specific seasons in mind
so that you're not trapped in a week of
conditions that you'd rather skip
entirely it's a small but good
improvement over the system that debuted
in forza horizon 4. progression has also
been slightly tweaked with less of a
focus on moving from one part of the map
to another as you complete events and
instead letting you author which events
you want to tackle and when as you
complete races take on open world
activities and engage with forza horizon
5's latest story events you'll be able
to spend points to unlock new tiers of
the festival this includes unlocking
access to specific race types such as
apex for standard circuit races pr
stunts for daredevil antics or street
scene for dangerous races in crowded
suburban areas each additional point in
each festival type opens up more story
specific events for that type consisting
of multi-tiered story missions and the
more traditional showcase events that
forza horizon has become known for
these story events all feature similar
formats that are changed up by the
racing style that they represent
dropping you in the most interesting
parts of the mexican map there are
ancient ruins and derelict airfields
ripe for exploration on the way to
setting up the next big racing festival
that unlocks even more points of
interest on the map
the most interesting of these are the
ones that pair you up with one of the
new team members and citizens of mexico
be it a talented mechanic or budding
university student looking for someone
with high speed data these carpool
sessions bounce between serious and
comical from poignant tales of the
importance of a car to a family and
over-the-top photo shoots that take you
through some of the worst weather the
region has to offer they each layer
familiar events time sprints to an
objective point scoring skill sessions
or massive physics-defying jumps for
example
they each layer familiar events with a
human element that has mostly been
missing from the series hearing your
created driver respond in these
dialogues makes each conversation far
less one-sided too giving your legendary
status as a master class driver more
texture than just a voiceless avatar
that does silly dances on the podium
forza horizon 5 is still miles away from
what you might consider as story driven
but these small detours do wonders for
the overall pacing when there's so much
racing to be done outside of them these
character-driven aspects are what stand
out the most in the latest entry in the
series and one that's required given how
similar it can feel without it the forza
horizon series has established a formula
that's been stuck to you quite closely
for several years now and while it
definitely doesn't feel stable in a way
that many other open world franchises
can it doesn't always have the grin
inducing surprises as it used to
playground games has a knack for great
exhilarating races across its incredibly
detailed world but there's not enough
here to convince you that this is the
entry to jump in if previous ones
haven't done it for you its changes are
profound enough for long time fans to
appreciate the change but they don't
have a significant influence on the
overall structure that the horizon
series has become comfortable with the
variety of race events can change over
time too especially as the community
engages with the tools that forza
horizon 5 offers to create custom events
each race can be altered by players and
played by anyone online giving the
already expansive number of races even
more replayability over time there are
new types of multiplayer modes too that
join the returning staples from the
previous entry forza arcade turns the
arcade racing into something even
sillier with a variety of mini games
contained in a small area of the map
that you collaboratively participate in
with other nearby players it's a fun
distraction as it stands but it requires
a bunch of players to pause the more
exciting prospect of head-to-head racing
in order to participate in without
offering the same captivating
competitive edge that the rest of the
strong stable of multiplayer modes do
being confined to a small area of the
maps is also counterintuitive to what
makes forza horizon's brand of open
world exploration so fun
playground games has iterated on its
approach to open world design over the
course of the series and horizon 5
epitomizes why it works so well it's
laid out so that you're consistently
rewarded for engaging with its world
even when you're just moving from one
race to the next speed traps drift zones
small duels with other races and just
simply traveling in style reward you
with points that drive forward overall
progression making each action feel
rewarding and purposeful it's dense with
activities without also feeling
overwhelming letting you map out routes
from events that are littered with side
activities that interest you to tackle
along the way in this way forza horizon
5 is another meaningful evolution of the
series as opposed to a reinvention but
that doesn't necessarily mean it's a
case of more of the same even when it is
familiar forza horizon 5 makes small but
thoughtful changes to its established
blueprint that hones in on the people
behind the cars in a way that the
franchise has previously just glossed
over its iterations to progression are
welcome too letting you focus on the
events that you love while also giving
you even more event types to make
effective use of the varied and fun map
that has been designed around mexico's
best hits it's not going to convince you
to give it a go if forza horizon's brand
of racing hasn't done it for you in the
past but forza horizon 5 still stands
head and shoulders above anything else
in the genre
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at xbox our passion is to help you find
and play the games that you love you
know i love the art form of video games
i think we tell stories that bring
people together whether it's competing
or whether it's cooperative this is just
what gaming should be about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
after all this time
it's special to be back here with xbox
fans around the world i mean just look
at this stage
that alone shows you how far we've all
come since 2001.
my name is robbie bach and i had the
privilege of being in charge of xbox
until i retired from microsoft in 2010.
when we started xbox 20 years ago the
original idea was a business venture a
way for microsoft to get into the living
room
but as we assembled our team and got to
work
xbox quickly blossomed into a new vision
for what games could be
an ethernet port to connect players over
the internet at broadband speeds
a built-in hard drive to help games
evolve beyond the limitations of disks
and cartridges
a global dedicated online service to let
you play with old and new friends alike
no matter where they are
these were audacious groundbreaking
ideas at the time
but they were also risky
we faced skeptics and doubters i'll be
honest and say inside and outside of
microsoft
we had missteps along the way
there were lots of challenges involved
in getting that first xbox out the door
in a way that was true to our vision
so when i think about what it took to
bring xbox to life i always remember
that success was not guaranteed
and it was your passion for what xbox is
that transformed that vision into
reality
a vision only comes to life when others
share a belief in what's possible and
for that we are grateful to all of you
our partners developers around the world
and most of all our fans
[Music]
microsoft is going to make a game
console we weren't sure how we were
going to do it risk was enormous
microsoft was this dominant company of
the era but success or even survival was
anything but preordained
we started to ship quality games and at
the same time we weren't doing anything
in the console space one day these guys
from the directx team walked in
we just thought of ourselves kind of
that rebels of a weird combination of
craziness and genius we were a renegade
team
a lot of our thinking was focused on
making the very best games that really
meant something for us
we wanted to make a console design to be
easy and fun to make games on
we were trying to crash meetings and get
traction on this thing
we were an annoyance you're proposing
taking money away from office in order
to fund some game system balmer
understood where the money came from
steve looked at the xbox idea and saw
insanity wait just one minute before you
answer what's the hard drive going to
cost what's the ethernet port going to
cost
there's no way
everything about making a console is
hard we made this little device it was
held together by chewing gum and pace
and it doesn't turn on and it became
clear that there was just some really
big challenges for us
the duke wasn't a small controller you
had to have gorilla hands to work with
this thing
it doesn't matter what your technology
is if you don't have the games we were
done they had this new thing called halo
forza was built as an epic racing game
gears of war was appealing to a hardcore
gamer we were focused on having all of
our games prepped for e3 and you're
always just one catastrophic bug away
from not making it
what's going on
the red ring of doubt microsoft brand is
on the line the microsoft names on the
line it's insane to launch a game
console when you're microsoft you made
freaking windows in a spreadsheet it was
chaotic chaos total chaos our goal is to
continue to innovate across all
platforms bridge the gap between
traditional and cloud-based games and
then sometimes there's surprises that
come out of nowhere
[Applause]
we are no longer in the microsoft
playbook
power on the story of xbox is a six part
documentary series that will release on
december 13th across a variety of video
platforms
so the project began almost three years
ago with a simple question
is there a compelling story behind the
history of xbox
the answer it turns out was yes
absolutely
so we partnered with an emmy
award-winning documentary film team to
really dig in and help bring the story
to life
at its core it's a story about how xbox
started as a passion project from a
small group of gamers within microsoft
and grew to become a source of joy for
xbox players around the world
whether you've been here for the entire
20 years or you have just joined us
we're excited to have you with us today
and we're going to relive some of our
favorite moments here's some words of
wisdom from our very own bill spencer
and definitely have a little bit of fun
well thanks rock and it really is an
honor to have you here believe it or not
i'm a big fan of yours for instance i
know that you're a five-time wwf
champion not to mention one of the top
entertainers in the world
bill i'm very flattered i'm a big fan of
yours as well
for instance the rock knows you're the
chairman and chief software architect of
the microsoft corporation a leading
worldwide provider of software for the
personal computer
thank you rock i'm i'm very flattered
myself by creating windows by creating
windows in 1983 a multitasking graphical
user interface environment that runs on
ms-dos based computers along with
windows nt and windows 2000 completely
self-contained operating systems that
feature networking uh symmetric
multi-processing multi-threading
and
security bill you've certainly
revolutionized the technology we know
today
wow
rock
that is impressive so
for the first time let me now unveil
xbox
[Applause]
[Music]
i think this is going to be looked back
on
the golden age
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hi everyone i'm phil spencer known on
xbox as p3
i've been playing video games pretty
much my whole life
i actually joined this company as an
intern but i was still in school a long
time before xbox was even a concept
so when i think about 20 years of xbox
and what games mean to all of us
i always come back to the fact that
around the world gaming is all about
people
that's it
games are all about real people coming
together to create experiences and
relationships that cross geographies and
cultures and age and all the things that
can separate people in other parts of
life
personally i've been fortunate to see
that power of gaming to connect people
in a few ways
at work the best part of my job is
spending time with the ridiculously
talented teams both here at xbox and
across our industry
you gaming creators around the world are
at the forefront of the world's most
exciting art form
but the reality is that as an industry
none of our work comes to life until
it's enjoyed by our players
you the global gaming community are a
powerful force
and it is you've made our passion as
popular and important as it is today
pretty much every day when i'm off work
i'm on xbox i'm chatting with friends
we're driving jeeps off cliffs and forza
i'm trying new games in game pass
this is where we live and we've all seen
how important and real those human
relationships can be
especially in the face of real life
adversity
so when i think about 20 years of xbox i
think about you our community and our
creators
and i want you to know that i'm
dedicated team xbox is dedicated and
this company is dedicated to continuing
to invest
listen and learn as we build the best
most welcoming and most fun
entertainment ecosystem anywhere on
earth and beyond
at xbox we're on a mission to bring the
joy and community of gaming to everyone
and we're honored that you've joined us
for the last 20 years and we can't wait
to build the future together
so thank you and see you online
his name is jacob i met him like three
years ago on call of duty black ops
three so over the next year he quickly
became one of our best friends we're
meeting for the first time but of course
it was only online i've never seen him
in person tanner lives in spokane
washington but i was like bro i want to
be in canada no way he's here
it's just so crazy
now let's pack up and head to st louis
[Music]
that's
xbox
[Applause]
since the launch of xbox one we've
listened to you the community of xbox
gamers and we're grateful for your
continued feedback
we continue to deliver monthly platform
feature updates that enhance your gaming
experience and your response to the
updates continues to motivate us
last year the team decided to tackle a
feature that has been consistently at
the top of your request list and while
we weren't sure it was possible
today
i'm pleased to announce xbox one
backward compatibility
your xbox 360 games
the games you've invested your time and
money in
and the games you want to continue to be
play will be playable natively on your
xbox one
[Applause]
you asked for more games to join our
backward compatibility catalog from the
biggest blockbusters to cult classics
and we listened today we are celebrating
our anniversary by adding more than 70
original xbox and xbox 360 games to our
backward compatibility catalog
the entire max payne series is now
playable on xbox series x series s and
xbox one consoles for the very first
time
the entire fear franchise can now be
played on our latest machines
games like dead or alive ultimate and
star wars jedi knight 2 jedi outcast are
once again playable on a new generation
of consoles
all original xbox games will look better
than ever on all modern consoles
every one of the titles added today will
benefit from auto hdr and many will
enjoy increased frame rates with fps
boost including a wider range of our
existing backward compatible titles like
the gears of war franchise the fable
franchise
cameo and sonic generations at xbox we
are committed to preserving the games
that you love enhanced by the latest
technology while staying true to the
original creator's vision
what better way to celebrate the past 20
years than by playing the iconic games
that helped define it thank you for
being with us on every step of this
journey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you ever wonder what the bottom of an
avatar shoe looks like
well bam there it is
[Music]
next time
[Music]
all right xbox fans the time has come
can you believe it has been 20 years
since i stood on that ces stage in las
vegas and helped launch the original
xbox now of course i nailed all the cool
buzzwords the rock's here to say that
that can't be farther from the truth
symmetric multi-processing completely
self-contained operating system and how
about that look i mean the outfit the
glasses who wears glasses inside and i
even had hair back then those were the
days the good old days now thank the
lord i left the fanny pack in my closet
all right well i hope you had a chance
to watch red notice on netflix over the
weekend now here's the thing we built a
kick-ass vault
inspired by the film with some amazing
treasures and artifacts from xbox over
the last 20 years now look my co-stars
ryan reynolds and gal gadot being the
master thieves that they are they are
hell-bent on getting into the vault and
getting their hands on these artifacts
themselves so i need your help i need
you to break into the xbox vault
yourself by heading over to the site
below
now i'm excited to tell you we got
hundreds and hundreds of amazing prizes
including an oil painting of yours truly
from that moment 20 years ago the look
the glasses the hair the whole thing is
there and custom xbox red notice
hardware game pass collectors cards we
got hundreds and hundreds of them for
you guys and last but not least
three cleopatra eggs just like the ones
in red notice all right it's time for me
to go and hit the iron paradise and show
master chief what uh real guns look like
you never cease to amaze the rock enjoy
the rest of the show
[Music]
oops
[Music]
all right i think i'm gonna be going to
bed
[Music]
all right
[Music]
please welcome kiara reeves
hello los angeles
yeah the feeling of walking the streets
of the future
is really going to be breathtaking
you're breathtaking
you're all breathtaking
[Applause]
more than just fun it's an activity that
brings people from all walks of life
from all over the world together
congratulations thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
important
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
online
the vision that we've worked on for so
long you see it in real products xbox
one x
the most powerful console ever made
that journey from vision to reality
isn't always a direct path
we see a future where you're instantly
absorbed in your games where worlds are
even more like-like
immersive
responsive and surprising
we centered on this idea of putting the
player at the center
really freeing up the player to play the
games that they want with the people
they want on the devices that they want
to play
xbox will be the platform that underpins
gaming experiences for the globe
that's the vision
it will connect people
it will empower creators to achieve
things they never could before
it will break down barriers
that's what i believe
[Music]
a milestone like the 20th anniversary of
xbox is more than a chance to reflect on
all we've done and everything our
players have taught us
with 23 studios across xbox game studios
and bethesda all pouring their
incredible passion into creating new
worlds and amazing experiences the
future of gaming is awe-inspiring
at xbox our love for players starts with
our love for games and the creators who
make them
we know that to reach more gamers in
more parts of the world we need to keep
bringing more creative voices and
perspectives to the table
fostering a community as diverse as the
world we live in and inclusive of all
that makes each of us who we are
that's why we relentlessly invest to
make it easier and faster for developers
to build the games we love
we've driven innovation to enable
developers to build accessibility
features into their games like
remappable controls and adjustable color
or text for players who are visually
impaired
we collaborate with creators to
encourage representation of diverse
characters for stories that can open our
eyes and our hearts to new points of
view and we're committed to bringing
those incredible games to every gamer on
the planet by making it possible for
anyone to play any game anywhere
we do that with game pass bringing you
hundreds of titles from hidden gems to
the biggest hits playable across all
devices we do that with our consoles the
most affordable and powerful console
lineup with xbox series s and x and we
do that with things like the xbox
adaptive controller which has unlocked
the joy of gaming for over 400 million
players with disabilities
when everyone plays
we all win it isn't just a tagline it's
a core principle that inspires
everything we do
so please join us as we look forward to
the next 20 years and more as we unleash
creativity embrace a global community
and delight gamers everywhere
together thank you for being the core of
what makes xbox great
our duty as soldiers is to protect
humanity whatever the cost
hello master chief
[Music]
i'm so fortunate to be able to work and
play in this incredible sci-fi universe
of halo
like marvel and star wars halo is a
universe where hundreds of stories can
be told and where millions of
experiences can be shared
halo began 20 years ago as the defining
experience for xbox
and thanks to you it's now a global pop
culture phenomenon
whether it's the highly anticipated halo
tv series coming to paramount plus next
year which you just saw a glimpse in
that live-action teaser or stepping back
into the boots of master chief in halo
infinite this december the halo universe
continues to expand in new and thrilling
ways
because of your passion for halo
and your constructive feedback we gave
halo infinite more time
to refine it for everyone that has been
with us from the beginning
and for anyone who's just getting
started
this game is returned to our roots with
an epic campaign and a deeply rewarding
multiplayer and we can't wait for you to
jump into this all new halo experience
while the master chief is the hero of
halo
our fans are its heart and soul
and we at 343 are proud to celebrate 20
years of halo with you in a very special
way enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
hello halo community from all of us at
343 industries
[Applause]
to everyone who played in the recent
multiplayer flights your passion and
feedback and spectacular gameplay clips
inspired all of us as we made the final
push to get halo infinite ready for
launch as a thank you and to celebrate
our 20th anniversary we wanted to do
something special so let me hand the mic
to tom french creative director for halo
infinite multiplayer tom thank you
joseph on behalf of the entire halo team
it's my honor and privilege to announce
that your spartan journey begins today
right now you can download and start
playing season 1 of halo infinite's free
to play multiplayer beta on xbox one
series s x and pc
this is the kickoff of our season and
you'll have access to all the maps core
modes academy features and the full
battle pass to unlock and your
progression will carry over when we
officially release the game on december
8th
this is an amazing moment for our team
to get to celebrate this as we finally
get to release the game and play with
you online see you online spartans
[Applause]
you built this facility off the grid to
train the next generation of spartans
to be a spartan you must become
the impossible
greeting spot it would be my pleasure to
serve at your side
an electric kill
on your feet
a ninja
[Music]
[Music]
zone captured
[Music]
[Music]
you